liebe freunde keiner mag sie ja das kann
man noch verstehen denn hast macht
hässlich dass und hass macht hässlich
das ist auch der grund warum ich so
viele koops nasen und kinderschänder
also hier liebevoll nicht sagt aalens
die afd ist eine schande für deutschland
und eine schande für jedes deutsche
parlament liebe freunde da können sie
noch so blöd oder so hässlich sein
keiner braucht sie wahrscheinlich war es
die generation vorher auch so man liest
und hört ja dass eure eltern meistens
geschwister waren
und wenn ich mir das eine oder andere
gesicht genauer anschauen meine damen
und herren dann habe ich fast den
eindruck als wären die haustiere auch
nicht weit gewesen
vielen dank und jetzt der höhepunkt des
abends sie gilt und beim sex zu bleiben
als wandelnde matratze produkt zumindest
politischer inzucht die hat hug fresse
der nation alles weil ich hoffe sie ist
noch da